hello there today we're looking at
involution
inverting the inheritance of convolution
for visual recognition
by number of researchers of the hong
kong university of science and
technology
bite dance ai lab and peking university
in this paper on a high level the
researchers
try to replace the good old convolution
operator in cnns by this new thing
called an involution in its essence
involution is about halfway between a
convolution and a self-attention
kind of operation and turns out
that with some clever weight sharing
scheme
you can achieve very good performance
compared to
cnn's and self-attention networks while
keeping the number of parameters
and the computational cost relatively
low
this i think is very much worth trying
for anyone
who does not operate on extremely large
scale
problems um yeah so
we'll get into that a bit more when we
go into the experiments but for now
let's go through the paper through what
involution
is what it does how it's different and
yeah so if you like this
you know don't hesitate share it out it
would
help a lot we're on the road to 100k
subscribers
and with every subscriber i get a
subscriber i stole that joke
um so they say here in the abstract
convolution has been the core ingredient
of modern neural networks
triggering the surge of deep learning in
vision which you know correct uh
alexnet resnets etc convolution
even though transformers are slowly
taking over computer vision
convolutions are still very very much
uh used and if you're not on a super
large scale
problem a convolutional neural network
is still
very probably the best way to go if you
have a computer vision
problem they say we rethink the
inherent principles of standard
convolution for
vision tasks specifically spatial
agnostic
and channel specific instead we present
a novel atomic operation for deep neural
networks by inverting the aforementioned
design principles of convolution
coined an involution okay and they say
we additionally demystify the recent
popular
self-attention operator and subsume it
into our involution family as an over
complicated instantiation so
the um a lot of statements in this paper
are let's they are true uh
especially further down a lot of the
experiments are really cool
but it is a bit of an overstatement uh
what they say
uh right here so their claim
is that in if you have a convolution
what you do
you do something that's spatial agnostic
and channel
specific which means that in a in a
convolutional neural network
when you have an image let's say
with a bunch of pixels these are now
true pixels not
patches and you run a convolutional
layer over it you run a convolutional
kernel over it
you put the center of the kernel at some
pixel
then so the kernel will be something
like
a three by three kernel you put that on
the center here
so it overlaps here you multiply element
wise
and then you aggregate and you can do
that in multiple channels but
essentially you do that
and then after you've done that you move
you move the kernel
one let's say to the right you shift it
so the center is here you do the same
thing again
and you shift it you do the same thing
again so it's spatial agnostic because
it repeats
the same computation over and over and
over across the image
and it doesn't care where the
computation is
right it does the same computation and
that is the selling point of
convolutional
neural networks they are translation
invariant this is
it's a form of weight sharing right you
share the weights across the locations
and therefore you don't really care
where stuff is in the image that the cnn
will be able to recognize it
just as well and you don't need to learn
over and over and over the same
principle just because it's in different
parts of the image
so this is spatial agnostic what does
channel specific mean that for that we
have to go
into the multiple channels uh
realm so if if your image
has multiple channels let's say i draw a
new image
right here with a bunch of pixels
and it has multiple channels that means
you can
imagine it sort of as a as a 3d tensor
here
where each pixel is a column
and every column is
a vector of a certain dimensionality
i mean so the original image has of
course
three channels which is red green and
blue
but if you have intermediate
representations
these channels can grow to sizes of
hundreds of channels
and the the point of the channels is
every entry here is a number
and every number can sort of capture
one aspect of what's described in that
particular pixel right so maybe the
first channel
is uh is there a corner the second one
is there an edge
the third one is there is it was it
originally a blue pixel
uh the fourth one is there probably a
cat here and so on so that
these are like the different features in
in the channels
and the convolution operator is channel
specific that means
if you have the kernel now convolutional
kernels
aren't as easy as i drew them they're in
fact
four dimensional tensors so
that is um
they are four dimensional tensors which
makes it a little bit
complicated for me to draw honestly
however if you you can imagine that
you have one kernel
like so okay that has the same
amount of channels as your
image okay so now you can still do the
same operation right you can overlay
your kernel on a part of the image
you can overlay it like so and
no that's in the back and then you can
do element wise multiplication and then
you do an
sum you sum it all up right after you do
this operation
you do a big sum over all the elements
of
whatever your kernel multiplied with
your image
and that gives you one
number you do an all reduce one number
gives you one number and
so you do this so this is one kernel
but you have another one right here
um yeah like this
and you do the same thing and that gives
you
also one number and you have another
kernel i think you you get the idea you
have
another kernel here so you have many of
those kernels per
layer when you actually if you've never
looked at you know
how the weights look when you
instantiate these layers in a deep
learning framework
encourage you to do so right a a
convolutional layer
will have weights that are of the size
kernel size
by kernel size by input channels
by output channels so it's a 4d tensor
and this the orange part here
is just one of those
sub tensors in fact you have
as many as you have output channels
and that gives you of course when you
then go over
all of these that gives you the next
layer so that becomes in the next layer
um
so this is the next layer representation
right at the point where you
overlaid the the kernel in the last
thing
that will become this column right here
okay so you have the orange thing in the
first
the blue thing in the second channel
green thing in the third channel and so
on
hope this is relatively clear so you
have in fact
one convolutional kernel per output
channel okay so if if you call the
orange thing here a convolutional kernel
then you have one kernel per output
channel
and that means it's channel specific
okay so this um
this is a conscious choice and it makes
sense when you
think about it because the each output
channel
means something different right if i
want if my output channel
means is there a cat at this particular
location then i might want to aggregate
the last layer's representation
differently
than if my output channel says well
is this uh part of the sky or
if the is is there a corner here or
something like this
so i want to aggregate the weights
differently that's why i have to have a
different set of
weights here here and here because
they mean different things so
it's spatial agnostic because it does
the same computation
at every location it's channel specific
because it does a different computation
at each channel even though it does it
for all the locations
equally all right so now we're prepared
to
invert that so convo involution promises
we invert this what we want to do
is something spatial specific
and channel agnostic okay so
the first the first thing here is the
channel agnostic
um if you've seen my last video about
mlp
mixer this is very much the same
idea and the idea is just of hey why do
we have different things here
uh why do we have different computations
can't we just
you know apply the same principle we
apply to the spatial
thing uh where we say you know we just
slide the same computation over the
image and that
is generally fine that's weight sharing
it's actually good um why don't we just
do this here
why don't we aggregate the information
in the same way for for all the
the different channels and yeah
so you can do that you can just have one
kernel
so instead of having a number of output
channels many kernel
so you the involution will come up
with simply one kernel
that it shares across all of the
channels they have a little picture down
here
and just look at the at the last step
right here
so here well sorry i crossed that out
here this is the kernel that they they
have
um sorry it's not even it's not even by
number of channels it's actually you
just flatten
this thing right so it's a k by k by one
kernel and you simply push that
put that over a location in the image
and then you share the computation
across
so the the image here given that this is
all in the same colors it means that
you just multiply you broadcast that's
the word i was looking for you broadcast
the operation
across the channels and then you
aggregate
after that so you can see what
involution does
is broadcast and then not reduce
right you don't reduce at the end to a
single number
but you keep the uh channels
the the channels as they are that's why
you only need a k
by k pi one because you don't have the
different computation for each output
channel
and you don't reduce across the input
channels
so you get away with with a lot less
parameters
so i that's even wrong here just a k
by k kernel now
that's that's one part the other part
is why don't we do something that's
um spatial specific
spatial specific and now remember what
spatial agnostic was spatial agnostic
was is
we slide the same kernel across
the image what they're saying in first
instance
they're saying things like um or they
said something
don't know where it was in the picture
but
they say well what we could do is if we
have an image
right if we have an image big image
and we do something spatial specific
what that means
is we could have a kernel that's
just as big as the image right then
no more no more sliding across it it's
simply
you multiply those things together you
broadcast it across these uh
across these channels of the image and
there you go
right that's that's it also
uh something that that mlp mixer does
right they they just say whatever
we don't do slidey slidey anymore um
we simply i mean they they do weight
sharing
but essentially you're trying to get rid
of this
sliding over you have different weight
for each location
and that means that the computation
actually differs
from where stuff is in the image and we
know that that
is somewhat important because usually
the sky
is up and uh
you know objects in these natural images
that humans take might be more in the
middle
than anywhere else and text goes from
left to right
and so it's not all super translation
and location invariant
so it makes sense to have weights that
are different
for each position but then they run into
a problem they say
we we couldn't do that very well
because now um
now it we we can't just input
pictures of different resolutions right
that's one problem i think the other
problem is
that this might not work too well
um so they come up with a different
thing they say
can't we make a compromise and they
don't call it a compromise
they they call it something different
but they they say
look can we come up with a scheme where
we can retain
a kernel that's approximately
this size like a small kernel but
it is different for each location so we
still do the
sort of classic convolution way of doing
things in that we do
these local aggregations across
neighboring pixels
however the kernel that we use here
is different from the kernel that we use
here and that's different from the
kernel that we use
here so how could you make a computation
where the kernel is always different you
do that
by coming up with the kernel in a
dynamic way
so the the authors here they say okay
if let's say we're at this pixel right
here we care about this
neighborhood how can we come up on the
fly
with a kernel for this particular
pixel and their answer is
well let's just generate it from the
pixel so this
is the full involution diagram we've now
arrived
at this so they are at this neighborhood
which is
outlined here in this black um black
scaffolding grid
thing the center pixel is the red pixel
here this one and they say
we look at that pixel and all its
channels
and we use that pixel and only that
pixel so not the neighborhood we use
that pixel
to come up with the kernel so they have
a computation here which of course is
going to be a a small neural network so
this is a two layer
uh neural network that comes up with the
kernel you see this
this is simply a here is just a reshape
this so you compute
the kernel across the neighborhood
from the pixel itself okay and that
means that
every single pixel here
unless it's the exact same uh pixel
so the exact same color in the first
layer but or the exact same
representation
in the intermediate layers every single
location gets its
own kernel for the convolution
the computation i've already told you is
a
small neural network specifically it's
sort of a bottleneck
neural network so it takes the pixel
uh representation as a vector sort of
bottlenecks it
there is a non-linearity here and then
it expands it again to the size
of the actual kernel okay
and then you use that kernel and you
broadcast it
instead of having one kernel
per input channel and then you multiply
and then you don't reduce
by across the input channels okay
sorry uh yeah i said that's it
and and that alleviates you from having
to have multiple kernels one for each
output channel okay now
this is the whole involution pipeline
there are
i would say there are multiple different
concepts here
so this coming up with the kernel on the
fly is one concept
and then this broadcasting scheme is an
entirely different concept you could do
both independently of each other and
they do them together um
which which i yeah they do ablations
further down um but it's sort of two new
things
in one now the first thing here is very
much
you might you might think of a tension
mechanism
as you um as you look at that
because it's a form of fast weights
right so the weights of the computation
they are computed on the fly
from the data itself and that is exactly
what an attention mechanism does however
here you do it in a slightly
different way and they say that
they have a discussion across
about attention right here so they say
you know there are there are a bunch of
differences
so in attention what you'd have is
you don't only have you don't only
compute your weights
from the actual location where you are
even in local
self-attention you actually compute your
weights
from more than just the pixel where you
are you compute it from the entire
region you care about so that's the
first thing
and then the second thing is you don't
in self-attention you have the queries
and the keys right so
you have your your data your
neighborhood
let's say and each of those things
produces
a query and
a key right query and i'm going to write
the key
up here everyone produces a query and a
key
and then you do this sort of quadratic
thing in order to determine what like
how
you should aggregate your information
not in involution in involution you
simply don't produce keys you
only produce queries if you will or only
keys
however you want to look at it and then
you don't do the quadratic thing rather
you
immediately interpret this as sort of
the weights
of aggregation you can write this and
they say that you can write this
you can interpret this as the positional
encodings already being
present in these weights because it's
now
specific to a position whereas in the
attention literature you'd have to
supply positional encodings
so in order for the algorithm to know
you know that that this is a different
thing sorry
that this here is a different thing from
this thing here you need to supply it
with positional encodings
not here because you know the individual
channels
of this thing immediately refer to
different
positions right here so the this neural
network is very
aware what position is where relative to
the pixel you're considering
so they say this the success of
involution explains in part
uh why other people had lots of success
with leaving away the keys and only
using positional encodings
together with the query and if i'm not
mistaken
this is a thing i think you could frame
the lambda networks
into this category where um
at some point like they never do this
attention
however they they only they rely
heavily on positional encodings however
you can
learn those ahead of time right or or
statically
all right that's enough of a
so this is the connection to attention
the connection to attention is the
weights are constructed on the fly
however
here there's no quadratic interaction
um there is no soft max and so on just
you construct the weights
from the pixel in the center
uh therefore it's less powerful to frame
attention as like
well it's a more complicated
instantiation of our idea
that's a bit that's a bit out there like
the authors here they say well attention
is just a more complicated
thing of our thing and the second thing
i i worry a bit about is this is they
say well this is
um position specific or location
specific
right they started out with saying
convolution is spatial agnostic
we want to do something spatial specific
this here is also spatial agnostic
like if if you get the same pixel at
different locations in the image
this thing will produce the same weights
and the computation
will be the same in fact you do this
entire computation right here
that is a spatially agnostic computation
it's just so the difference here is the
same difference that you have
between slow weights and fast weights
where
you simply construct the weights of the
actual computation on the fly
however the way you construct these
weights
it remains position agnostic so that's
the first thing
and the second thing yeah the weight
sharing i feel is a bit of independent
thing now i get it that the two work
well together
but the the broadcasting and weight
sharing thing across the channels
it's it's almost a separate um much
simpler uh mention and it's a bit
related to so if you have a
if you have a depth uh separated
convolution and you simply share the
weights across that
that's about what it what it boils down
to so
so what does that give us in fact it
gives us
a lot in this paper they do experiments
and they compare against uh for example
so against
resnets and other networks with similar
number of parameters
and i like these experiments here in
that you can see they always
make sure that they have the lowest
number of parameters
among the things they compare with right
yet
they show that they still beat uh these
models
they still they still are better than
the models they compare to
so they do that and specifically i guess
they compare to
res net with the same number of layers
standalone resnet this i think is
self-attention
um i think they here's this axial
resnet so that has a little bit less uh
parameters interestingly enough but
yeah so you can see that this
outperforms
on these tasks right here
so this is imagenet they also have
different things
such as this segmentation task
i think they have a picture down here
the segmentation task where they
perform better so here i think this is
the baseline and you can see
the involution network it does a better
job
at this kind of things which which is
believable
i think the effect that you see right
here the fact that
the fact that you're they are better in
this number
is really cool and it's probably a bit
you know due to the fact
that they do this on the fly computation
of weights which
is a more powerful idea than the static
weights of a convolution
and then the lower number of parameters
i think is more a result of their weight
sharing scheme right they tout here
how that they um
is on par with resnet 101 regarding the
top one recognition
accuracy while saving
65 percent of storage and
computation so i think that the saving
of computation is more
due to the weight sharing mechanism
and i think they've they've just here
selected tasks and they might be
important tasks but i think
it was just the case that in these tasks
um
the whether or not you share the weights
probably doesn't matter
doesn't hit you as hard or is even
beneficial if you don't have enough data
and therefore that's why they have less
parameters
so um this what you can also observe
here is that differences
they get continuously smaller as you
move up the scale
of network now this is all on the same
data set but it would be interesting to
see how this
performs on you know really large scale
because my
my intuition is that you know as
you go larger and larger in scale this
approach is gonna is gonna top out
and lose out to the more general
architectures like
attention and you know whatever mlp's
apparently it's a clown world now
but in in the regimes in these regimes
and i
would argue these are the regimes where
a lot of practitioners
care about these and actually smaller
regimes so not many
people are in the super high data regime
this seems to perform
reasonably well right um
so you can see right here the the the
curves
here uh when you compare compute to
accuracy is
very favorable um as a
again especially if you're in like this
region
here uh if you're in the in the low
resource region it might be something
that you want to
try out it remains to be seen how
how well this is pre-trainable and
fine-tunable
and so on but it's something you might
want to
try also if you try try to
only use sort of parts of it it would be
interesting to see
you know if we if we still do
convolution
but we do this sort of weight sharing
scheme this broadcasting scheme
[Music]
and yeah they also have a notion of of
grouping
in in the channels so as
i think the i think as the attention
mechanism
yeah has it so they here they say it
however sharing a single kernel across
all channels obviously underperforms
inaccuracy
uh considering channel redundancy of
involution kernels
as long as it's setting the channels
shared in a group to an acceptable range
channel agnostic behavior will not only
reserve
i guess preserve the performance but
also reduce the parameter count and
computational
cost this will also permit the larger
kernel size
under the same budget so it's sort of
the same reasoning
as people introducing groups or
different heads
in multi-head attention yeah
so try all of this stuff out i think
it's worth it the code is available
code is available right here
and i'll also put a link to that
and that was it from me for this paper i
wish you
a very pleasant whatever
the day of the week is and bye bye